hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
you're probably happy enough playing Red
Dead Redemption 2 or blackest for right
now but with a new month comes new game
releases desperately attempting to grab
your attention
here's 9 heavy hitters and a few hidden
gems worth your time in November or
maybe they're worthy enough to make it
onto your Christmas list without a doubt
the biggest game of November in my eyes
is the return of agent 47 in hitman 2 if
you don't know hitman is a methodical
stealth action game and is as much about
your awareness of the situation as it is
your skill and precision 47 travels all
over the world taking down targets after
target with garrote in hand maybe a
sniper rifle or even the fabled
accidental kill completing a mission
undetected is extremely satisfying but I
tend to take down every single person in
a digital bloodbath let's quickly set
things straight 2016 s hitman performed
badly due to an episodic approach which
put up a paywall after a paywall not the
case this time lessons have been learned
hitman 2 has a complete campaign
available from day one with constant
updates such as elusive targets where
you are sent to eliminate target during
a small window of time fail and that
target will never return again the first
one is none other than Sean Bean the
pressure to get things right first time
is nerve jangling but on the other hand
it's just as much fun attempting to
murder eyes everyone hitman 2 also
includes a first-person sniper mode and
the new ghost mode which begins to see
hitman move into multiplayer as you can
see what your opponent is doing all the
time like a ghost I'll have a full
breakdown of everything new in hitman 2
coming very soon here's one I have muted
hopes for Darksiders 3 releasing on
November the 27th Darksiders is a
hack-and-slash action adventure game
which has always achieved impressive
review scores in the past to me
Darksiders felt a great deal like the
original god of war games but now the
God of War series is steering towards
RPG inspired elements fans of the
original Kratos outings should
definitely consider dioxide as 3 the
story revolves around the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse and the impending doom
that brings Darksiders 3 actually runs
parallel to the other titles but in this
one we take control off fury
she's enigmatic she's unpredictable she
has a bit of a temper
and she's damn arrogant too she's
perfect she's tasked with tracking down
seven deadly sins and destroying them
what do you think fancy some hack and
slash action docksiders three released
on November 27th on ps4 PC and Xbox one
it's becoming a trend to release classic
games in remastered glory just before
the Christmas rush and this year it's
the turn of Spyro the Dragon this is the
Spyro reignited trilogy as the name
suggests this is the first three outings
for the purple dragon Spyro the Dragon
Spyro 2 riptos rage and Spyro year of
the dragon small changes that have made
a huge impact include the voice actor
Tom Kenny returning to reavoice Spyro
this allowed the team to go back and
rerecord the original game audio as back
then it was voiced by somebody else the
continuity certainly helps if you don't
know Spyro it's a puzzle platformer it
was originally made for children so
don't expect a huge challenge right away
the game looks impressively polished and
is perfect for a holiday gift this
Christmas look out for this one on
November the 13th when you think of
first person shooters your mind either
picks out Call of Duty or battlefield
this year black ops 4 pulled the trigger
first and received great reviews even
without the story German campaign most
likely that due to the blackout battle
royale mode while battlefield 5 is ready
to fire back this month as always the
battlefield offers the more realistic
first-person warfare when compared to
Call of Duty but due to the release date
slipping this has me worried EA have now
decided to release battlefield 5 on
November the 20th but origins
subscribers can play from November the
9th and deluxe owners can play from
November the 15th these types of mixed
messages will impact the game's success
but I still hold faint hope that
battlefields upcoming version of battle
royale could be the greatest ever if it
actually gets a solid release date that
is sorry to sound so down on this one
battlefield 3 was my Bey once upon a
time just as I'm recording this ea have
confirmed Battle Royale won't reach
battlefield 5 until spring 2019 Oh No
I'd love some opinions on this one am I
overreacting or is this going to be DOA
let's look at rec fest rec fest was
originally released on the PC earlier in
the year but finally jumps to console
on November the 20th at present this is
a ps4 console exclusive did you ever
play Destruction Derby on the
PlayStation I'd like to think of rec
fest as the next step in our series
collisions happen regularly doors fly
off bumpers trail on the ground and
destruction is an understatement there's
20 tracks with the typical reversed
options and 40-plus vehicles with
customization to boot if you're into a
bit of Karen car action and obliteration
is your thing
check out wreck Fest on November the
20th another game jumping over to ps4
this month is the forest this is an open
world survival title which stops us out
as a plane crash survivor your son has
gone missing so off you go into the
wilderness to find that little
whippersnapper the game simply releases
you into the world and that's it do your
own thing
find your kid or frolic to your heart's
content the forest features are crafting
mechanic to make weapons shelters and
all your equipment
it also supports 4 player cooperative
play the forest comes to ps4 on November
the 6th here's a game with drastically
conflicting reviews and previews fallout
76 by now we all know the formula of
Fallout games survive the
post-apocalyptic wasteland with the
general themes such as finding your
killer searching for your child's are my
personal favorites romancing paladin
dance yeah
fallout 76 throws this formula into the
air and starts again
thus infuriating some diehard fans
fallout 76 is an always online
multiplayer role-playing game the game
world will feature no NPCs instead the
only human beings will be real-life
players in the world the game is set in
West Virginia I'm sure you've seen the
countless adverse and features a map 4
times bigger than that of Fallout 4
which was bloody huge we're one of the
first vault dwellers to break open the
vault and attempt to reclaim America
will this be a success or maybe it will
be a slowly improving online model
similar to that of Elder Scrolls online
time will tell fallout 76 releases on
November 14th I'm gonna give it a try
what about you ok a really quick one
here because I really need to understand
the appeal farming simulator 19 please
can someone explain why this is an
annual release what changes in the world
of farming I live
Yorkshire and it's absolutely packed
full of farmers so I'm perplexed by this
game can someone make me understand
please you know what would you be
interested in a farming video should I
buy farming simulator 19 and make a
video I'd love to know your thoughts and
finally let's talk about Red Dead online
by the time this releases which is said
to be late November we should have
completed the single-player portion and
be ready to jump in online with our
friends and become an outlaw gang
robbing trains and planning bank heists
if GTA online is anything to go by
Rockstar will be adding online content
regularly think about the possibilities
of Red Dead online buying your ranch and
completing farming jars
hang on we've already talks about the
last game what about by England going
straight defending from bandits going
head to head with other gangs taking on
the Pinkertons there's so much potential
in Red Dead online it will likely break
down a few times during the beta period
but once it's up and running this could
be a game-mode to last those years so
there we have it 9 games and expansions
to tempt you in November what you're
grabbing for me it's all about agent 47
I apologize in advance for all the
reckless hitman videos incoming and of
course I have to try Red Dead online I'm
Adam from Playstation grenades been a
pleasure see you next time
[Music]